collider has this so this is uh you know
I I I've seen this story and I've been
trying to get some confirmation for it
and I haven't I I don't know I don't
even know if this is true or not but it
says uh over the years it's been said
that laughter is the best medicine in
the modern well okay I don't need any of
that who cares I don't need to read that
the article is basically that they're
they're coming up with a reboot of the
office that's the claim anyway I've seen
this
reported it's all over the headlines
that they're doing a reboot of the
office and then I've tried to not that
I've a lot of time researching this very
important topic but I've wondered where
is that coming from who said that
they're doing a reboot and I haven't
quite found that but um that's the claim
anyway it's not it's not a big
shock because because of course as we
know Hollywood has completely run out of
ideas I mean that didn't happen recently
they've they've been running on fumes
they've been running on Creative fumes
for uh really decades
now and so now they want to reboot the
office which uh doesn't make any sense
on multiple levels and the the the first
level where it makes no sense is that
the office is already a reboot there's
the UK office and then it was and then
that that show
ended and that that was a show that
actually knew how to you know like tell
the story get the jokes across and then
get out that was two
seasons uh two seasons of the original
office was two seasons long and each I
think each season was like six episodes
like there was like 12 or episode total
for the whole show could have could have
kept going but uh they said we've told
the story we don't need to keep going
there's not a whole lot else to say here
we got the point across then it was
rebooted with the office and uh that was
funny for three and a half seasons and
then it just fell off a cliff and it
kept going for another six Seasons or
something and uh and now they want to do
and then they already had offshoot like
Parks and Recreation so they had kind of
like these these sort of offshoot
related cousin type shows and now they
want to reboot they want to reboot the
reboot
um but of course the the main reason why
this is a terrible idea is that as uh
many people have pointed out I'm
certainly not the first but a show like
that simply just can't exist in modern
society now it can exist like some of
these shows they can be and and films
and things they can be sort of
grandfathered in because they already
are there and they're part of the the
Zeitgeist and and they're part of the
culture and so you know and so they're
allowed to continue sort of existing in
memory but
um there's just no way that something
like that could be made could actually
be made now you couldn't do
it it's like a movie like uh Mrs doubt
fighter or something yeah that that's
out there no one has circled back to
cancel it yet uh lots of people in the
90s when they were growing up saw that
movie could that exact movie be made now
no hell no a movie where the whole joke
J is that a guy's dressing up like a
like a woman it's like it's funny we're
laughing at
him which is which is you know back
historically you know if Hollywood had a
a plot line where a guy's dressing up
like a woman it was always that's
ridiculous it's crazy let's laugh at it
this is like a it's a clown this person
is a clown now doing this for our
Amusement so you can't do that anymore
and you can't have the office
anymore because they're telling jokes
that are related to race and ethnicity
and sexual orientation and you know
everyone's kind of Michael Scott's the
butt of the joke but but everyone's kind
of the butt of the joke and you're
having fun with all these different
things and it just can't exist anymore
humor cannot exist in this Society
unfortunately thanks for checking out
this video if you'd like to listen to my
full podcast on the go you can check out
the Matt wall show on Apple podcast
Spotify or wherever you get your podcast